one Texas City is trading public buses
for ride-sharing Arlington introduced
commuter buses in 2013 but now the city
has abandoned them replacing them with a
new partnership with the ride-sharing
company via vans pick up passengers on
demand for a three dollar ride Arlington
is the first US city to experiment with
this kind of venture Kris Van Cleave
went to Arlington to show us the
cost-saving innovation good morning this
is where you used to wait for a bus in
Arlington Texas but you'd be waiting a
long time now as the sign says the city
dropped its bus service going for more
of a virtual bus stop that you summon
with an app and here is what the new
city buses look like it's actually a
rideshare arlington texas wants to know
if this could be the answer to mass
transit in the uber age the city
partnered with app based ride-sharing
service via to operate 10 vans to
shuttle residents replacing the city's 4
year-old commuter bus service the
commuter bus didn't apply to me at all
because it didn't take me where I needed
to go since January bill O'Toole's left
his car at home and commuted with via
summoning the van from his phone for a
flat fee of $3 a ride or a weekly pass
for 10 bucks the fees are partially
subsidized by the city stress at work
has been alleviated and it's probably
just the fact that I'm not starting
stressed
you really hate driving I really hate
driving getting around Arlington without
a car is not easy it's a sprawling
community of 99 square miles and sits 12
miles from Fort Worth and 20 from Dallas
but Arlington residents have repeatedly
voted against spending money to build a
mass transit system when the bus line
was scrapped ridership had fallen to as
little as 100 people a day on its single
route through downtown
do you see buses and rail as passe as
outdated technology absolutely III think
that with the new technology that's
coming on you're gonna see very little
lot rail built because this is so much
cheaper Arlington mayor Jeff Williams
it's a pilot program you know if it
didn't work well we can go on to
something else and it's a fraction of
spending 50 million
a mile for library arlington residents
are taking to the virtual buses in its
first month via provided more than 5,000
rides at a 97% customer approval rating
thank you so much Alex Lavoie from via
we're gonna pick you up within a block
or two of where you want to get picked
up we're not gonna pick you up at a few
fixed pickup locations within the city
it's quite a convenient solution and we
think for that reason people will really
enjoy it and so far they really happen
the city is planning on expanding the
program to cover a hundred and twenty
thousand of its residents by this summer
and if they're filling up the via vans
it looked to go citywide in the next
couple of years for CBS this morning
Kris Van Cleave Arlington Texas it's
working there thank you Chris very much